Sky News understands that Britain is in
discussions to send up to 10 tanks to
Ukraine and a major step up in support
against the Russian invasion our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
joins me now live from Kiev with more on
this story what can you tell us at this
stage Alex
well the fact that these discussions are
happening is hugely significant
obviously it will be even more
significant if tanks are donated by the
British and they you do see them on the
battlefield here but I think it reflects
what's going on uh wider amongst Western
allies remember that these discussions
are not just happening in London they've
been happening in Berlin they've been
happening in Paris and in the United
States now the Americans are already
going to provide combat armored vehicles
as are the Germans now the reason that
this is important is if you think back
to the beginning of the conflict there
was great concern amongst Ukraine's
allies that they didn't want to escalate
what was already a very bad situation
Vladimir Putin has set down some very
strict red lines there was a large
amount of nuclear saber rattling but as
this conflict has gone on I think there
is this sort of a sense really that it
can't escalate
um much more and that some of the red
lines that he has set are actually a bit
more more fluid and then you might have
thought now the other thing to bear in
mind of course is that Ukraine has had a
large amount of success on the
battlefield it has the momentum and it
has it has the initiative remember at
the beginning of the war of course
people think that this country would be
filleted by the Russian uh Army very
very quickly that hasn't come to pass at
all in fact quite the opposite and what
we're now seeing is that Ukraine
arguably in terms of military technology
now has a qualitative Edge to the
Russians with the kind of things that
they've been given think about the high
Mars This is an American long-range
artillery system it outperforms anything
that the Russians have had now when we
see these combat armored vehicles
provided by the Germans and the
Americans in theater and if of course
they're joined by British tanks again we
could see significant developments come
around spring when the weather changes a
little bit what you will see is that the
um the ukrainians then have the ability
ability to launch some pretty
sophisticated counter-offensives and you
might see them breaking through Russian
lands other lines at the line of contact
success is similar to what we saw in
cursing now the Russian reaction um to
all of this has been fairly Furious they
accused the Western allies of using
Ukraine and Ukrainian blood to weaken
Russia they argue that all will happen
is that this war will just go on much
longer they say that they will carry on
fighting they are a superior fighting
force and they will eventually win now
that may be true it may not be true but
I think in a response to this we are
most likely to see sometime later in the
New Year Vladimir Putin announcing the
mobilization of even more men but I
think the other thing to the other
takeaway point from all of this is that
this this war is not going to end in the
next couple of months it really is
probably going to take uh the next year
or so but there are certainly many
people in the west now who believe that
Ukrainian Ukraine can be victorious over
Russian forces